and finally new rule the ad slogan what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas must be
expanded to include the entire country
and then written into the Constitution
as a proclamation that we are tired of
everyone watching us all the time the
NSA tracks your calls your web browser
knows you like nipple slips and Verizon
knows when you call your dealer to ask
if those shirts came in last week I
bought a pair of shoes online I don't
know who told Facebook but now it thinks
I'm obsessed with shoes
listen Zuckerberg I don't need shoes
okay because I just bought some but you
already know that don't you and by the
way that inflatable doll I bought so I
can drive in the carpool and that's a
good idea
now there's an old saying that character
means doing the right thing even when no
one is watching well if that's true
people growing up today will never know
if they have any the sarbanes-oxley Act
that's a law that was written to stop
traitors from destroying records that
reveal fraud but now it's being used to
charge anyone with the crime of merely
clearing the browser history on their
laptop and if married people can't clear
their computers how can they indulge in
the sixth perverted fantasy life that
keeps their relationship healthy and of
course it's not just what you type
merely having your phone on you let
other people know exactly where you are
a spouse has to be Jason Bourne to get a
little action on a business trip you've
got five seconds when the drone blocks
the view of the satellite make it down
you know I've always said it's okay to
trade some privacy for security I have
asked anyone who reads my email but
there are over 6,000 surveillance
cameras on the streets of New York and
former Mayor Bloomberg said the argument
against using them is just this
craziness that oh it's Big Brother get
used to it I don't want to get used to
it I don't like strangers watching me
present company
but we're not all Cardassians we didn't
all sign up for this Donald sterling is
a man who was a number of not great
things like creepy and a bad team owner
and a slumlord and such a fool he
thought a young girl found him
attractive even though she had to wear a
welding mask but it's just plain
unamerican that he was drummed out of
his own life for something he said in a
private conversation in his living room
former House Speaker Dennis Hastert is
another creep but I don't see why he
should be indicted as he was for making
bank withdrawals of over 10 grand of his
own money which banks must report to the
government pastored as it turns out was
making hush money payments to a former
student he molested back when he was a
wrestling coach but he wasn't charged
with diddling kids
the FBI understands that's just a part
of being a wrestling Co no no no we got
Hastert for the inappropriate way he
touched an ATM machine now of course
it's easy to point to a Hastert or a
sterling or a wiener or a spitzer and
say oh look we caught a guy doing
something bad isn't surveillance great
no there's a price ask anyone over 40
how thankful they are that they got
their first job at a time when not every
stupid thing you ever did was recorded
and uploaded to the internet for all
eternity
I don't blame today's kids are being
overly medicated if I knew that was a
video out there of me twerking to
Nickelback passed out with a cat taped
to my not something I'd be on Zoloft ooh
we're not just changing how we live
we're changing human nature itself
because you know when everything is
recorded there isn't any right and wrong
for its own sake it's just caught or not
caught and perhaps even worse there's
never a moment when we can let our guard
down with everything always recorded
everyone starts altering their behavior
for the camera picks up for the cops
they could still get
you